it's an internationally unrecognized
border to a country that doesn't
officially exist the checkpoint between
moldova and its breakaway region of
transnistra is busy much more so than
usual
a wave of unexplained attacks in the
sliver of land between moldova to the
west and ukraine to the east mean
lengthy checks going in and out
locals can pass without special
permission journalists can't
people are nervous to speak confused
about what's happening the war in
ukraine's only 15 kilometers away
it's horrible what's happening in
ukraine we lived through war in the
1990s war only means one thing bloodshed
on monday there was an apparent rocket
attack on transylvania's security
service building in the regional capital
terraspol
the next day two soviet-era radio masts
were destroyed
and on wednesday transnistian officials
said shots were fired from ukraine into
the region close to a russian arms depot
ukraine calls the attacks false flag
operations a pretext for russia to
mobilize troops in the region raising
concerns that this could become a new
front in the war in ukraine
moscow denies it has its sights set on
transnistra
we strongly condemn attempts to drag
transgnestra into what's happening in
ukraine and we can hear some of the
sensationalist claims about preparations
by russian peacekeepers terraspal
airstrip and transnestron conscript for
some hostile actions
it's believed there around 1500 russian
troops so-called peacekeepers
permanently stationed in transnistria
they've been there ever since the war
between russian-backed separatists and
moldovan authorities in the early 1990s
the region also has a modest military
several thousand strong on the one side
of this thin border moldova a country
with eu aspirations
on the other a country not recognized
anywhere internationally that still uses
the soviet hammer and sickle on its
national flag
earlier in the week the moldovan
president maya sandu said unnamed forces
inside transnistra were in favor of war
the country's neutral under its
constitution
but it does have strong ties with the eu
and nato without being a member of
either
the war next door in ukraine suddenly
feels much closer
neve barca al jazeera the violets are
crossing moldova